the war in Ukraine is about to enter its
second year and Russia may be seeking
help from China that country's top
Diplomat met with Russian President
Vladimir Putin in Moscow yesterday and
Putin says he's looking forward to a
visit from Chinese president Xi Jinping
Zhang is at the White House where U.S
officials are very concerned about
China's closer ties to Russia we should
good morning to you good morning to you
Gail and good morning to everybody China
and Russia insists that their deepening
relationship has nothing to do with any
other country but experts on the region
say it is unquestionably sending a
message to the United States and now
there are growing concerns that Beijing
could Supply weapons to Russia as the
war rages on
President Biden returned to Washington
last night after a whirlwind visit to
Ukraine and Poland back in Warsaw
Wednesday the president underscored
America's allegiance to Nato members
from Eastern Europe we will defend
literally every inch of NATO just 700
miles away in Moscow another world
leader flaunted a powerful Alliance
Russian President Vladimir Putin met
with China's top Diplomat Wang Yi
declaring he was looking forward to a
visit from president Xi Jinping now U.S
officials are concerned that Beijing
will supply lethal Aid to the Russian
army what does China get out of this
public display of support for Putin at
this time on the one hand they don't
want Russia to lose on the other hand
they know that their economic fortunes
are tied to stable relations with Europe
and the United States Evan Medeiros was
the top advisor on the Asia Pacific in
the Obama Administration he says the U.S
China relationship is on a downward
spiral since the U.S shot down a Chinese
spy balloon that made its way over
sensitive military sites earlier this
month that incident combined with
wangi's criticism of the United States
and now his trip to Russia that clearly
has crossed that threshold into a new
type of Cold War and in a new interview
President Biden criticized Putin's
decision to suspend participation in the
last remaining nuclear arms treaty
between the U.S and Russia it's a big
mistake to do that not very responsible
President Biden went on to say that he
does not believe Russia's withdrawal of
that treaty means that Putin is actually
considering using nuclear weapons Nate
Ouija thank you